WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE CHAIR
RECOGNIZES THE GENTLEMAN FROM
ILLINOIS FOR A CLOSING
STATEMENT.
>> THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT LAWYERS
ARE NOT THE PRESIDENT'S PERSONAL
LAWYERS.
THEY COUNT ON THEM TO BE ON THE
SIDE OF THE LAW AND TO DEFEND
THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE UNITED
STATES, NOT THE BEST INTEREST OF
ANY POLITICAL CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S HOW IT'S BEEN SINCE THE
DEPARTMENT WAS FOUNDED SOON
AFTER THE CIVIL WAR.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT LAWYERS ARE
SUPPOSED TO PLAY IT 100%
STRAIGHT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIED TO ERASE
HIS LOSS AT THE BALLOT BOX BY
PARACHUTING AN UNQUALIFIED MAN
INTO THE TOP JOB AT JUSTICE.
IT WAS A POWER PLAY WITH NO
REGARD FOR THE WILL OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT WAS ABOUT IGNORING MILLIONS
OF VOTES, LABEL THEM CORRUPT,
ILLEGAL, WHATEVER.
FACTS WERE CLEARLY JUST AN
INCONVENIENCE.
FROM THE OVAL OFFICE, PRESIDENT
TRUMP URGED OTHERS TO BRING HIS
BIG LIE TO LIFE.
HE BEGGED, JUST SAY THE ELECTION
WAS CORRUPT AND LEAVE THE REST
TO ME AND THE REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMEN.
HE DIDN'T CARE WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S INVESTIGATIONS
PROVED.
WHAT GOOD WERE FACTS WHEN THEY
WOULD ONLY CONFIRM HIS LOSS?
AND IT'S NO SURPRISE THAT ALL
THE FAR-OUT, FULLY FABRICATED
WHACK JOB CONSPIRACY THEORIES
COLLAPSED UNDER EVEN THE
SLIGHTEST SCRUTINY.
THAT INSANITY WENT FROM THE
INTERNET TO THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT IN NO TIME.
THE BOTTOM LINE, THE MOST SENIOR
LEADERSHIP OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FROM ATTORNEY GENERAL
BILL BARR TO JEFF ROSEN, HIS
SUCCESSOR, EVERYONE WAS TELLING
PRESIDENT TRUMP THE SAME THING.
THE CONSPIRACY THEORYS WERE
FALSE.
THE ALLEGATION OF A STOLEN
ELECTION WAS A LIE.
THE DATA LEFT NO ROOM FOR DOUBT,
NOTHING TO QUESTION.
AND THE CONSTITUTION LEFT NO
ROOM FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
CHANGE THE OUTCOME OF THE
ELECTION.
BUT WE'RE HERE TODAY BECAUSE THE
FACTS WERE IRRELEVANT TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT WAS ABOUT PROTECTING HIS VERY
REAL POWER AND VERY FRAGILE EGO.
EVEN IF IT REQUIRED RECKLESSLY
UNDERMINING OUR ENTIRE ELECTORAL
SYSTEM BY WILDLY CASTING
BASELESS DOUBT UPON IT.
IN SHORT, HE WAS WILLING TO
SACRIFICE OUR REPUBLIC TO
PROLONG HIS PRESIDENCY.
I CAN IMAGINE NO MORE
DISHONORABLE ACT BY A PRESIDENT.
WE OWE A GREAT DEBT OF GRATITUDE
FROM THESE MEN YOU HAVE HEARD
HERE TODAY.
REAL LEADERS WHO STOOD FOR
JUSTICE WHEN IT WAS IN GRAVE
PERIL, WHO PUT THEIR COUNTRY
FIRST WHEN THE LEADER OF THE
FREE WORLD DEMANDED OTHERWISE.
THEY THREATENED TO RESIGN RATHER
THAN CORRUPT OUR DEMOCRACY, AND
THANKS LARGELY TO EACH OF THEM,
PRESIDENT TRUMP FAILED.
CONTRAST THAT TO JEFF CLARK, WHO
WOULD DO WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
WANTED.
MR. CLARK REFUSED TO COOPERATE
WITH THIS COMMITTEE.
HE PLED THE 5th OVER 125 TIMES.
WHY RISK SELF-INCRIMINATION?
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
CONGRESSIONAL FRIENDS, SOME OF
THEM ARE ANGLING FOR PARDONS.
THEY KNEW THAT EVERY BIT OF WHAT
THEY DID WAS A LIE AND IT WAS
WRONG.
THAT'S ALL THE MORE REASON TO
RESPECT THOSE WHO CAME HERE TO
TESTIFY TODAY.
WE THANK THEM FOR THEIR
UNFLINCHING SERVICE IN THE FACE
OF INCREDIBLE PRESSURE.
AS IT'S SAID, THE ONLY THING
NECESSARY FOR EVIL TO SUCCEED IS
GOOD MEN TO DO NOTHING.
THANKFULLY, THERE WERE GOOD
PEOPLE IN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
YOU HEARD FROM OTHER GOOD PEOPLE
TOO ON THURSDAY.
THEY TOO DEFENDED US.
I'M STILL WORRIED NOT ENOUGH HAS
CHANGED TO PREVENT THIS FROM
HAPPENING AGAIN.
THE OATH THAT WE TAKE HAS TO
MEAN SOMETHING.
IT HAS TO CUT TO THE CORE OF WHO
WE ARE AND BE THE DRIVING FORCE
OF OUR SERVICE TO THIS NATION.
WE ON THIS COMMITTEE, WE MAY BE
ABLE TO SHINE LIGHT ON THE
DARKNESS, BUT THAT IS NOT
ENOUGH.
IT'S NOW UP TO EVERY AMERICAN,
NOW AND IN THE FUTURE, TO STAND
FOR TRUTH, TO REJECT THE LIES,
WHEREVER WE CONFRONT THEM, IN
OUR TOWNS, IN OUR CAPITALS, IN
OUR FRIENDSHIPS, IN